[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] get cold in the summer bet my clock
make it hot in the winter
keep spinning 5 minutes we standing on
business
[Music]
[Music]
like a fan on my way to the city trying
to get [ __ ] killed before my flight
land killing [ __ ] boy that's my hobbit
one with the cylinder go body for body
try to slide my block gonna get your
[ __ ] stop like we valet parking [ __ ]
lightweight valet parking
[Music]
that was a crazy ass freestyle you know
we drop one every week brought to you by
lrg look check out the brand new lrg
duck down records collab the [ __ ] is gas
they got some crazy gear on the way but
the real important part is if you go to
their website right now l
r dash g dot com put it on the screen
you will get 30 off at checkout when you
use the code bootleg
30 off
of whatever you order at lrg that's a
big [ __ ] chunk of change all right so
go to the website use that promo code
bootleg get 30 off and we got another
freestyle coming next week